what i would like to do in this video is
explore the connection between the
binary number system which is clearly or
we've already talked about it as base 2
and explore the connection between that
and the hexadecimal
hexadecimal number system
which is base 16.
and the reason why this is interesting
is because 16 is a power of 2. and so
what we'll see is you can almost view
the hexadecimal number system is almost
a condensed representation of the binary
number system and this is actually why
you will actually we've already talked
about the binary system is used
extensively in computer science and even
in computer engineering it's what's
under it's the underlying things that
are happening or it's the representation
used when we're talking about logic
gates and transistors and things like
that but if hexad but hexadecimal also
shows up a lot because it is kind of a
condensed representation of base 2. so
what do i mean by that so let's write
out a
arbitrary
an arbitrary number in base two so let's
say i have one
zero one one
zero
one one one
so this right over here this right over
here is in binary and i can even write
in parenthesis that this is a binary
representation and i want to convert
this to its hexadecimal representation
and i encourage you to pause the video
and try it out on your own and i'll give
you a clue on on how you can think about
converting directly from base 2 to base
16. think about which what over here is
in the 16th place and what is the 256th
place over here and then that might help
you convert directly
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
and the the really fun thing about
between converting between base 2 and
base 16 is you don't have to well for
any bases you really don't have to go
through base 10
but these in particular it's it's it's
especially easy to go convert between
these two bases
and the realization that you have to
make is well what are the powers which
places here are powers of 16. so this
right over here that is the ones place
so one way to think about it is all of
this is going to tell you how many ones
we have ones twos fours
and eights but another way to think
about it is this is a count of of ones
all the way up to a potential of 15 ones
so this can count
so this is going to be between 0 and and
i'm going to write it down actually let
me write it down and let me write it
down in base 16. it's going to be
between 0 and f it's going to be between
0 and 15. so it's kind of a count
between of the number of
ones i guess you could say
then this is the 16s place let me do
that in a different color
this right over here is the sixteenths
place
and you can have between zero and
fifteen sixteens
so this is also going to be between zero
and f when you look at this four digit
binary number so once again this whole
thing right over here is essentially
going to tell you how many 16s you have
this whole thing is going to tell you
how many ones you have
and then the next four and we could keep
going although there's only one place
here we could go this right over here is
the 256's
place and so this is going to be this
next four digits we only have one right
over here but one two three and then the
fourth one this is also going to be
between 0 and 15 256's
so hopefully that helps you a little bit
actually if this was a clue i encourage
you to pause the video again and see if
you can represent this in hexadecimal
so let's let's try to work this let's
try to work this thing together so how
many ones do we have so what number is
this these four digits right over here
this is eight
plus four plus two
so eight plus four is twelve plus two is
fourteen so this right over here is 14.
how do we represent that in hexadecimal
well 14 is 1 less than 15 so it's going
to be e
so this is going to be e
this is
e
e is our hexadecimal representation of
the number 14 comes right before our
representation of the number 15 f
all right now how many 16s do we have
let's see i have no eights i have a four
and i have a two so we're going to have
six
sixteens
so we're gonna have six
and then how many two hundred fifty
sixes do i have well i only have one two
hundred fifty six
one 256.
so this number in hexadecimal
and now i could write that this is in
hexadecimal right over here is 1 6
e
and i guess you could maybe call this
666 16e
i guess 14.
yeah i probably have to come up with a
better a better way of reading these
hexadecimal numbers and if you're and if
and if you're curious what number this
is because we didn't have to go through
decimal just so that you can comprehend
it in the number system that you're used
to operating in one that's based off of
the number of fingers you have
feel free to do so